Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing where we left off with the
first verses that were sent to the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam
appointing him as a messenger and
sending him to the people of Quraysh.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent down
these opening verses of
he says subhanahua
[Silence]
Six commands that Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala gives to the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam here. This is the
beginning. If we were to say what are
the things that we begin with when we
teach a m someone who is new to Islam,
what would we begin with? We would begin
where Allah began. these main tenants of
faith that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
commands the preparation of the soul and
the most important priorities that the
Muslim has especially those who call to
Allah to prepare him to call to Allah he
began with
this is saying oh you who is swaddled in
his clothing or in his blankets. It's a
curious thing to say. It sounds
it sounds very curious especially if
a person is unaware of the story behind
it. But as we mentioned last time that
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam saw
Gibl the second time and he was again in
shock. He went back to his wife Khadijah
and he said,
"Cover me, swaddle me." And then these
verses were sent down.
Speaking to him who was swaddled and
covered. This has a physical meaning.
This has a metaphorical meaning, a
literal meaning, and a metaphorical
meaning.
Literally he was covered and swaddled in
his clothing and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala was speaking to him. But it also
articulates that that place of warmth
and comfort, you have to come out of it.
You have to emerge from that place of
comfort in order to make any progress in
anything that you're going to do. And
calling to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
one of the greatest responsibilities.
It's one of the most rewarding things.
But it is incredibly difficult. It is
not easy. People are very different. And
a prophet, a messenger, a scholar,
people who call people and remind people
of Allah in the last day, they stand
between people and their desires. And
people do not that. They don't like
it when someone tells them they can't
have something. When someone makes them
remember that this is wrong and this is
right and we need to do this and we
mustn't do this. This is something that
people will always
be in conflict with. And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is addressing him in
his state of being. But it's as if he is
saying come out of those clothing, out
of those blankets. Step out into a place
of vulnerability,
out of a place of comfort, into a place
of discomfort. That is where progress is
found. And so the essence of this
statement
originally is
and in one of the recitations it is
recited
but it is most prominently recited.
Why?
Because the T
and the D
both come from the tip of the tongue.
T D T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T T
T T D D D D D D D D D D D D D D D D D D
D D. They're in a very close place from
each other and they use the same part of
the tongue but a slightly different
place in the mouth. This is what the
scholars refer to as eaganos.
means that two letters come from the
same place which is the tip of the
tongue and when letters come from the
same place they are often merged into
the more powerful letter. So the T is
not as powerful as the D and it's not as
critical. Why? Because the T is
understood but the D is critical to the
structure of the wood of the word.
Therefore it becomes
And this is found all through the Quran.
All through the Quran, we find this
merging of similar of sim similar
letters. Why? For ease of for ease of
speech. I think perhaps every language
does this. Human beings they tend
towards efficiency.
So for instance, instead of saying I
would, I would say I'd
I'd right? Why is this?
Because that's understood. All we need
from that is the D to take the place of
that whole word and we can understand
that altogether. So we get rid of all
the extra. We trim it down. There are
times when mentioning the whole thing
might be necessary and it might
articulate a particular message. But
throughout the Quran, we find this
pattern of cutting away anything that is
not necessary to the meaning or the
understanding of what Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala is saying. So the original
statement is
but Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala changed
the into and merge them together into
he says
stand and warn.
Now the Arabs used to have an idiom, a
saying that they would say. They would
say,
"A naked warner." A naked warner.
Someone who comes
and
would for instance bring some kind of
terrible news, some impending doom.
They've seen an army on the way to
lay siege to the city. They would come
and they would warn everyone. And this
kind of warner would be referred to as a
naked warner. He would be referred to as
what? Aan.
So it's as if Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
is alluding to that that warn of dire
consequences
to those who refuse this message. You
are carrying the most dire of messages
and you are primarily a warner. Right?
And this is why the prophet
sallallah.aii was first encounter with
his people is he came and said people
came they congregated and he said if I
were to warn you of an impending doom an
army on the other side of this mountain
coming to you would you believe me? They
said yes.
He said then I am telling you I am the
messenger of Allah to you all and I come
just before a painful and terrible
punishment. All right. And so Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala is alluding to the
rigor of a person who carries a dire
message.
Oh, who who is swaddled in his clothing,
lose that and warn everyone. Be that
naked warner of incredibly dire
circumstances ahead for those who reject
this message. He then says,
"And your Lord exalt."
Notice the wording here. He didn't say
Allah. And he didn't say exalt your
lord. He said your lord
exalt.
It's curious.
And so anytime you see in the Quran that
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala ascribes
himself
or ascribes the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam to himself.
This carries a huge amount of meaning.
So here he is saying
your Lord, oh Muhammad, your Lord. What
does your Lord mean? What's the
difference between the Lord and
Muhammad's Lord? The Lord of Muhammad
Sam.
What's the difference when Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says you must
worship
his Lord? meaning Muhammad's Lord. It
means you cannot just worship anyway.
You have to worship him in exactly the
way that Muhammad instructed with
exactly the belief that Muhammad brought
and articulated about his lord. So here
we have that connection
betweenahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillahoolah.
It's not just any lord it's lord
sallaiam.
And here he says,
so he didn't say exalt your lord. He
said your lord exalt
which is strange for the verb to come
after.
But in Arabic what this means when we
see this kind of switching of places and
switching around in the sentence. This
articulates at hass meaning exalt your
lord in a way that only is for your
lord. You cannot exalt anyone or
anything else in the way that you exalt
your lord. This is a specific type of
exaltation. Can a person exalt his can a
person exalt the Muslim? Exalt his
father. Exalt his mother. Exalt his
teacher. Exalt a scholar. Exalt a
parent. Yes. Exalt the me. We exalt the
messenger Muhammad sallall.aii wasam.
Correct. But none of those are exalted
in the way that Allah is exalted. We
exalt Allah absolutely and
unconditionally.
And this is only for Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. He then says,
and your clothing purify. Here we have
the same thing again. He didn't say
purify your clothing. He said your
clothing purify your your clothing. So
he began with his own clothing. This
again has a physical, a literal and a
metaphorical meaning. The literal
meaning is purify your literal clothing
from that which is filthy.
And the scholars of Phil use this verse
as an evidence that a person's prayer is
invalid if they pray knowingly with
filth on their clothing or on their body
or on their place of worship.
However,
this also has a metaphorical meaning
because
in the Arabic language
comes from the root word.
Focus with me.
This root word
elicits
the feeling of that which returns to a
person. So for instance, what do we call
a person's reward for good deeds?
The right thoubb. This is the why is
that? Because when you do this good, the
good will come back upon you.
They refer to clothing as a thie.
Why is it called a th because it's
proprietary belongs to me. I'm the only
one who wears it. And it is the most
specific thing I own to me because I
actually wear it on my physical body. So
it's referred to as what? A th No matter
where I send it off, it always comes
back to me and ends up on my skin.
Right? And so the th here met physically
means your physical clothing but
metaphorically it is your actions and
your deeds. So when Allah says
purify your deeds of that which is
indecent and illicit that which is haram
purify your deeds. When you open the
books of you find the companions they
explain this same verse. Some companions
say purify your clothing for salah.
That's correct physically the literal
meaning. And then other companions will
say this verse means
purify your actions of vulgarity and
indecency. That which is not
permissible. That which is haram. Purify
your actions. Where do they get this
from? from the literal meaning of the
word th other other scholars of will say
meaning never be treacherous anytime you
give your word follow through. Why?
Because the Arabs would say if someone
is trust trustworthy they would say
this person has very clean clothing.
What does that mean? It means that
there's a trustworthy person. When they
say something, they do it. They follow
through with it. They mean what they say
and they say what they mean. And so here
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is saying,
"Purify your physical clothing. Purify
your body physically. Purify your deeds.
Purify your word. When you say
something, adhere to it. When you give
or participate in a treaty or a truce or
an agreement or an alliance, follow
through to the end. No matter what this
here is called
this verse means all of those things.
When you read books of and you find
different opinions on the same verse,
this is rarely ever clashing opinions.
Rarely ever can you find a companion who
says this verse means yes and the other
companion says this verse means no. It's
almost impossible to find complete and
utter differing amongst the companions.
Rather what there is a lot of and a
plethora of is what is referred to as
differing in variety. What does that
mean? If I were to send four people out
here and I say, "Each one of you go to
one side of this building that we're in.
This one goes to the north, the south,
the east, the west. Everyone take a a
side of the building." And then I were
to say, "Describe to me what you're
looking at right now." Would their
description match? It wouldn't match.
They'd all be describing something
different, right? One would see a
different shape. one would see a
different kind of wall. However, they're
all describing different parts of what?
The same building, the same thing.
Therefore, when the companions mention
different opinions, they're not
different opinions. They're describing
different aspects of the same exact
thing.
We will stop there for this evening.
We'll continue this inshallah tomorrow
night.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.